Well, joining me now to discuss
this standard, the world's most
influential progressive online
channel, The Young Turks and
Democratic presidential hopeful.
That's Genk Hugo Jiang, great to
have you on the programme. Thank
you very much indeed for joining
me. I've been following your
tweets with interest. This week,
you've been getting increasingly
angry, I think it'd be fair to
say that I'm now enormous ly
frustrated by us and Israeli
government's barbaric acts in
Gaza. I will not be shy in
sharing that opinion on Piers
Morgan show today. Why are you
so frustrated? Yeah,
well, honestly, I didn't expect
the framing that you put on this
segment. And it's framing like
that. That's disgusting. So I
don't see what this has anything
to do with anti semitism. I
formed Young Turks and TYT with
two Jewish friends who are some
of my friends growing up, and
we've known each other and been
brothers for over 40 years now.
So I think what Hamas did is
disgusting. I cry for those
Israeli innocent civilians. But
do I see you guys crying for
Palestinians? I mean, Chris
Christie was just on here,
treating it like it's no big
deal, because what Palestinian
lives don't matter. I think the
real bigotry here is saying that
Palestinians we can kill three
times as many of them already.
And this is the appetiser,
Netanyahu and his barbaric
government have not even started
the entree of murder and death
and mayhem they're about to do.
And that's somehow Okay, killing
three times as many Palestinian
civilians live on the
occupation, which is bigotry, by
definition, we say that everyone
in the world can defend
themselves can have their own
state can have sovereignty,
except the Palestinians. And the
reasoning behind that is the
Palestinians are what are their
what? The idea is that they are
savages. And that Muslims are
too violent and cannot control
themselves. So they must be
occupied for 56, brutal,
disgusting years. So I've had
enough of the bigotry against
Muslims and Palestinians. And I
need you to speak out against
that, instead of covering every
outrageous atrocious action of
the right wing government of
Israel, and God, oh, it's anti
semitism. No, when and there is
global anti semitism. There's
anti semitism here in this
country. Two synagogues were
shot up Pittsburgh, and in
Southern California. We fight
against that all the time. But
then whenever Israel is
criticised, you people go, Oh,
no, it's anti semitism. No,
there's real anti semitism.
Instead of attacking that, all
you guys ever do is hide behind
the veil of anti semitism. Do
you know what? These might not
like? Israelis? Let me let me
repeat the sixth straight year
i Hey, I, hey, let me respond. A
or not you guys, I don't think I
fit into any neat fit on this
issue at all. Be I've actually
covered the story, I think more
fairly than most people, I've
had many pro Palestinian voices.
I've given a huge platform for
they've been getting enormous
audiences from Bass abusive to
others. And I've done that quite
deliberately. Because I think
these voices, I think these
voices are important to be
heard, including yours. I
certainly wasn't accusing you,
by the way or your organisation
of anti semitism, but just the I
have found it. As somebody who's
always identified as liberal
myself, I found it very
dispiriting to see people who
call themselves liberals, who,
whose instant response, it
seemed to me to one of the worst
terror attacks we've ever seen,
was to immediately side with the
place where these attacks have
been launched from now, I don't
tar all Palestinians with the
brush of being harassed at all.
And in fact, the sooner Hamas
are out of there, the better for
the Palestinian people and the
world. But I just think the only
human response you can have is,
as you did, by the way, to your
credit, is it was disgusting.
What happened on October the
seventh? Now the question then
becomes, what is a proportionate
response by Israel, not just the
material attacks of October the
seventh, but obviously, there is
now a huge ongoing escalation in
what has been, as you rightly
say, a 56 year war effectively
in varying degrees over that
period. And that's where I think
I'm struggling to see how a
ground invasion by Israel with
all that that would entail,
particularly mass deaths of
Palestinian civilians, how that
is going to do anything for any
peaceful resolution to this, I
think it will have the opposite
effect.
Yes, so let's say you one at a
time, first of all, as you
rightly point out on Young
Turks, we covered the atrocious
actions of Hamas, right from the
get go and we condemned it as
fully as anyone can possibly
condemn it. Because not only are
they killing those poor,
innocent Israelis that didn't do
anything, those little babies
and the grandmothers, it's
disgusting what they did, but on
top of that, they've They're
ruining the Palestinian cause
they've burned the moral high
ground to cinders. And then on
top of that, they smear all
people of Muslim background like
myself. And then it leashes this
unleashes this bigotry of anti
Muslim bigotry throughout the
world I'm sick of. So screw
Hamas and their barbarism. Okay.
Now in terms of a proper
reaction, yes, you need to get
those hostages out. So now let's
look at what I'm going to
suggest what to actually do I'm
going to be constructive. But
first let's look at the
unconstructive solution that
Israel had dropping bombs on
residential buildings 50
Ambulance ambulances have been
hit 10 out of 25 hospitals don't
operate anymore. The incubators
are about to run out of energy,
there's 45 babies that might die
today. The parents I just read
on CNN are writing the names of
the kids, on their calves on
their legs, so that if they are
killed in a bombing and they're
mutilated, they can find their
bodies. Imagine writing the name
of your child on their legs so
that you could find them in the
rubble after Israel or any
government drops a bomb on them.
And I need the West understand
something bombs kill people. And
you know how they kill people.
They incinerate them alive, or
their heads explode. So what
happened in Israel was, was a
disaster and disgusting. Well,
you have to be equally honest,
and it and equally outraged at
the immorality of incinerating
babies and grandmothers and
aunts and uncles, which is what
we're doing right now. America,
saving aid for death and
destruction, enough emasculation
ended today and today, it's
monstrous. Okay, I'm gonna take
let
me ask you this. Let me I
completely understand your
passion and your anger. I
completely get this. I like you
want to see some resolution at
the end of this horror that
we're witnessing? How do you get
rid of a mass? If you don't do
it the way Israel are currently
doing it? How do you actually
eradicate what has become a
nihilistic ISIS style terror
group who've quite deliberately
in my estimation, committed an
outrage of such appalling scale,
that they knew that this would
go to Israel into this kind of
response. So why they did that?
What is motivating it? Who might
be putting them up to it? Who's
helped them prepare for this?
These are all questions we don't
know the answers to yet. But it
seems to me that Israel could
have it's not Castle be being
lured into a massive trap here.
And I hope that is not the case.
But I'm curious, how do you get
rid of her mass? If you don't do
it the way Israel is currently
doing it, albeit with horrific
collateral damage in the face of
1000s of innocent Palestinians
being caught up in the bombing?
Yeah, so let me give you a short
term answer a long term answer.
And a lot of people are not
going to like these. But these
are realistic ways that you
minimise minimise civilian
casualties. You do what America
did with Osama bin Laden raid.
We didn't go drop a nuke on
Pakistan. We didn't go destroy
6000 residential buildings in
the middle of Pakistan, we sent
in Special Forces. Is it more
dangerous to the Special Forces?
Of course, that's the point of
special forces try to find the
hostages doesn't look like
Israel is trying to find the
hostages. If I have a family
member, that's a hostage. I'm
disgusted what by what Netanyahu
is doing now? How do you know
they're not in the buildings?
You're dropping bombs son? How
do you know they're not in the
tunnels you're dropping bombs
on? How do you know they're not
in the hospital. So you're
dropping bombs on. So this if
you want the hostages rescued,
every rational human being can
agree this is not the way to do
it. This is the way to do death
and destruction for the sake of
death and destruction. It's
collective punishment. It's
genocide against Palestinians.
And the world has to speak out.
So my way is not pleasant
either. It involves a lot of
folks dying on on both sides. I
understand that those are super
hard choices. But go find Hamas,
go find the hostages, go rescue
them instead of wanting really
intense indiscriminately killing
after killing. And let's be
honest, when you drop a bomb,
and a kid's head explodes, and a
grandmother is incinerated, that
is terrorism, killing three
times as many civilians as Hamas
is terrorism. And it is the same
if it is done by a government
sending as many special forces
you got we should send look
sending whatever you got to
actually do the job at hand
instead of what you're what
Netanyahu is doing, which is to
kill these people to watch send
a message and think about how
unrealistic that is. And think
about why his chance and his
method has a 0% chance of
working. How are the
Palestinians supposed to rise up
against Hamas? How They prove
they're against Hamas. Hamas
ended all elections Hamas ended
democracy. So how are the
Palestinians supposed to cry
uncle? They're already crying
uncle, but it's never enough for
the bloodthirsty Netanyahu, no
more deaths of Palestinians war
babies killed. That's what his
answer is. And it's this and the
United States of America, I'm
running for president here.
There's no way in the world I
would allow this sending $105
billion. That's and it doesn't
even go to Israel, Ukraine or
Taiwan. It goes to the defence
contractors that get abroad,
these greedy American
politicians, and then get most
of that money. And so the long
term answer is 9067 borders and
the biggest walls you've ever
seen in your entire life, and no
one's allowed to cross the
either side, but the
Palestinians get their state, it
is unconscionable for them not
to get their state. And if
you're a moral person, you of
course, you believe that the
Palestinians are not the only
people in the world that cannot
govern themselves. If you say
that you are being by
definition, a bigoted and a
racist, we have to have a two
state solution. immediately,
immediately. If 56 years of
occupation and brutalising these
people is not enough. It's 57
years going to be enough is 156
years is going to be enough. I'm
asking Israel not out of hate
out of love. So many of my
friends that I grew up with are
Jewish, this is not good for
them. This is not good for
anybody. Please look into your
hearts look and be the moral
people that I know you can be
abunda Passover dinners, where
you pray for your oppressors.
Now, it breaks my heart But I
gotta tell you, you gotta pray
for those who are oppressing and
to say that you are not
oppressing them. Palestinians
after brutalising them for 56
long years. You're kidding
yourself. And as a friend and an
ally. I'm trying to get you to
wake up and snap out of this
trance. You cannot keep doing
this. It is ruining your moral
fibre.
Jeong Yuga Thank you very much
indeed for joining me. I greatly
appreciate I'm sorry, it was
your first appearance on this
programme under these
circumstances, but I won't be
your last. I think you're an
important voice in this and I do
appreciate you coming on the
show. Thank you very much. Thank
you